[Applaudissements]
accueil triomphale pour Daniel Smith qui
sera la prochaine première ministre de
l'Alberta l'ancienne chef du parti
wardrows a été choisi par les membres du
Parti conservateur uni pour succéder à
Jason Kenny elle sera à fermenté mardi
prochain comme première ministre dans
son discours de victoire Daniel Smith
t'a dit vouloir défendre la liberté
individuelle vouloir contrôler les
dépenses publiques et développer le
potentiel énergétique de la province
quels seront les défis économiques de
Daniel Smith et de l'Alberta avec nous
Charles Saint-Arnaud il est économiste
en chef d'Alberta centraux qui est le
centre de services centralisé des
caisses populaires de l'Alberta bonsoir
Monsieur Saint-Arnaud bonsoir alors
d'entrée de jeu là expliquez-nous les
grandes lignes de ce projet de loi qui a
proposé d'agnol Smith en campagne la loi
sur la souveraineté de la liberté admise
beaucoup de là-dessus mais ça soulève
quand même la controverse disons qu'on
n'a pas nécessaire
en fait les grandes lignes c'est
l'alberto veut se donner le droit de
refuser de mettre en place les lois
décidées par au niveau fédéral et tout
réglementation aussi du niveau fédéral
donc tout ce qui est bien contraire à
l'heure ce qui décide de serrer leur à
leur bénéfice ils devronter de ne pas
les mettre en application donc plus
d'indépendance si on veut mais c'est
controversé on le disait l'opposant de
danios mitravistase laissait entendre
que cette loi-là ça pourrait carrément
créer le chaos dans le milieu des
affaires faire fuir des investissements
et des capitaux qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
un élément d'incertitude politique et
économique
aux investissements dans la province
donc on peut imaginer c'est peut-être
pas nécessaire mais on peut s'imaginer
une entreprise qui doit décider entre
investir à Calgary ou recouvert peut
peut-être décider de d'aller avant
couvert plutôt que juste à cause de
cette incertitude là économiquement
monsieur Agnès
beaucoup plus de ce côté-là ou le
laisser faire et beaucoup plus important
qu'est-ce que ça peut vouloir dire c'est
une approche comme celle-là pour
l'économie de l'Alberta par exemple
s'imaginer beaucoup plus de
déréglementation beaucoup plus comme on
dit de laisser faire beaucoup plus de
moins de dépenses publiques moins
d'investissement ou de réglementation
publique dans les dans les affaires
économiques donc c'est surtout ça qu'on
s'attend
la victoire
par toutes les industries mais en
particulier l'industrie des
hydrocarbures l'industrie pétrolière
qu'est-ce que cette victoire là veut
dire pour le secteur pétrolier
malheureusement je suis pas garantie que
ça va te donner changer grand chose je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup de rancune face
à l'activité complètement la quantité de
pipeline qui ont été ou de dire qui ont
été cancelés dans les dernières années
le problème c'est qu'on voit que déjà
des changements structurels dans
l'économie ou dans la façon de
fonctionner de l'industrie par exemple
on a des revenus records d'environ 12
milliards de dollars par mois dans
l'industrie pétrolière en comparaison en
2014 environ 7.7 milliards donc 75% plus
élevé mais on n'a pas le bon économique
qui serait normalement attendu des
revenus aussi importants c'est parce que
les pétrolières retournent beaucoup plus
de ses besti de leurs revenus aux
investisseurs aux actionnaires et
investissent beaucoup moins dans leurs
opérations locales donc il y a beaucoup
moins d'écouter cet argent qui demeure
en Alberta et c'est pas quelque chose
qui va changer mais on a l'impression
par contre Monsieur Saint-Arnaud que
Madame Smith est peut-être même plus
comment dire que les pétrolières sont
plus vertes que la nouvelle future
première ministre est-ce que c'est le
cas c'est probablement le code donc il y
a eu beaucoup de commentaires de la part
de Madame Smith que qui nous fait
entendre qu'elle est plutôt du côté ne
crois pas nécessairement à 100% le code
des changements climatiques et des pacte
humain sur les changements climatiques
donc ça va amener une approche très
différente par contre les pétrolières
font face à des pressions mondiales pour
améliorer leur à leur bilan donc ils
vont devoir suivre la tendance cela dit
les prix de l'énergie se sont raffermis
depuis le début de l'année et ça a fait
en sorte que l'Alberta est passé d'une
prévision de déficit à des surplus
importants dans les coffres les finances
publiques l'alberto se sont rarement si
bien portés on vous parlait d'un surplus
prévu 13 milliards de dollars d'ici la
fin de l'année est-ce que Madame Smith
prend les commandes dans une bonne
période elle va avoir des moyens
oui elle va avoir les moyens la question
c'est est-ce qu'elle va utiliser les
moyens bon faut dire que on va avoir des
élections provinciales en mille années
prochaine donc on peut s'attendre à un
peu plus de dépenses pour justement
améliorer cette situation au moins pour
aller essayer de le chercher un peu plus
de sport parce que demain que Madame
Smith n'est pas seulement très populaire
à l'extérieur de son parti ou à
l'extérieur des membres de son parti
donc on peut s'attendre à ça par contre
on sait qu'elle est beaucoup plus pro
en fait contre les taxes c'est pas
nécessairement contre quand les dépenses
publiques on peut pas s'attendre à ce
qui est beaucoup de réinvestissement de
ces surplus voyez quand même plusieurs
candidats dans la direction dans la
course à la direction du Parti
conservateur unique qui ont qui avait
pris l'engagement de continuer à aider
les Albertins pour atténuer l'impact
l'inflation on pense à la suspension de
la taxe sur l'essence qu'on voulait
prolonger les rabais sur l'électricité
et le gaz naturel est-ce que daniosmitt
à l'intention de s'inspirer de ça et
d'aller de l'avant elle aussi disons que
si on regarde ce qui CRS les Albertins
l'inflation et l'augmentation du coût de
la vie et le l'inquiétude la numéro 1
des électeurs donc ça serait une très
bonne stratégie pour elle d'essayer de
mettre des politiques en place pour
aider les Albertins donc la question
c'est est-ce qu'elle va le faire et dans
quelle mesure et quel genre de mesure
elle va mettre en place est-ce que son
plan éc
onomique beaucoup de points
d'interrogation encore est-ce que son
plan économique était bien défini bien
déterminé est-ce qu'on sait finalement à
quoi s'attendre où il y a plusieurs
interrogations encore
disons que ce qui nous a laissé sur
notre faim et surtout pour nous les
économistes qui regardent l'Alberta
c'est que les défis économiques ont pas
pris aucune place dans les débats dans
la course à la chefferie tout ce qui est
de prix de place a été le côté de la
souveraineté ça a pris 90% du temps
d'antenne et des discussions donc ça
nous laisse un peu sur notre fin on sait
pas vraiment à quoi s'attendre comme
politique économique au courant des
prochains mois oui et ben on va suivre
ça de près évidemment monsieur saint-ard
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là ce soir
merci bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]